[Música]
de lo que voy a hablar es de lo que me
ha enseñado el agua
hay un lugar común del que venimos todos
el cliente de una madre
hay un medio
en el que hemos crecido
el agua
esta realidad
está escrita en los mitos más antiguos
de todas las culturas
es que el agua
genera esta primera esfera viva en la
que crecemos
y luego se convierte
en el medio que habitamos porque
habitamos una esfera pasamos de habitar
una esfera desde el interior
habitar una esfera en el exterior pero
no hemos dejado de vivir en una esfera
lo que estoy tratando de hacer
con mi trabajo esto que se puede llamar
con pompa o sin pompa un vínculo entre
arte y ciencia es un ir cada vez el
corazón
es vinculada
el sentido común con la red de realidad
natural con eso que sucede
cotidianamente y que palpita en nuestros
cuerpos y que nos conecta con una
totalidad
pero que a nuestra cabeza se le olvida a
ratos
ahora
igual podemos encontrar algunos
referentes para mantener esa conexión
con alguna más clara con algo más de
claridad
son un par de semillas de trigo
el vídeo debería ser 2
horizontal
esto qué es esta línea que está en medio
debería ser horizontal para mostrar que
las raíces
hacia abajo y la hoja va hacia arriba
una polaridad básica y dos tendencias
curiosos
esta danza que vemos tan chula
responde una realidad natural es que las
células de estas pequeñas plantas están
creciendo en espiral
y naturalmente
hacen este movimiento
[Música]
y esto
es lo que olvidamos
las plantas lo saben las plantas lo
recuerdan
y gracias a ese hecho nosotros los seres
humanos y los animales podemos
alimentarnos
de la luz que viene del sol y qué es
transformada por ellas en materia
eran plantas de trigo
esto es parte del viaje
el comienzo de todo
viene con un trabajo que desarrolla
a partir de haber encontrado un medio
que era un blanco más intenso que el
blanco del papel
y mira que es testarudo para ponerse a
buscar una cosa tan rara pero bueno a
veces el arte
la percepción
de un estado de cosas que no acaba
desde entrar en armonía con tu propio
ser interior tengo sea buscar y a buscar
a veces obsesivamente
estas mariposas
son presencias ilusorias de mariposas
colombianas
y están hechas
en esta técnica
vitral por reflexión si pudiéramos tener
ahora lo tenemos
esto no sé si lo alcanzamos a ver
brillar
esta técnica reproducción de una manera
muy exacta los vídeos y colores de las
mariposas reales entonces las imágenes
que veis
son imágenes
de unas pinturas
el fondo es opaco la pintura es
transparente a través de un espejo como
allí
y la luz entre el cuadro y se devuelve
al ojo es un vitral por reflexión el
vital de las iglesias funciona por
transmisión de luz estamos dentro vemos
la luz que entra a la iglesia y vemos a
luz tenida
en este caso está este juego simple que
da una sensación de tridimensionalidad
de réplica de una manera muy muy precisa
los colores de las mariposas que son
ópticos funcionan por descomposición de
la luz no porque
no son pigmentos como estos son luz
descompuesta una mariposa colocada
contra la luz como esta que genera una
cantidad de colores absolutamente
fascinante es
un objeto pálido
pero cuando recibe la luz explota
estas mariposas que estas presencias
ilusorias son una propuesta de
contemplación
y son un cuestionamiento la depredación
en aras de contemplar belleza los seres
humanos buscamos la belleza como una
manera de completarlos
es curioso siempre la buscamos pero la
belleza en la naturaleza la de verdad
está determinada por una relación
esencial
qué es la relación que será el hilo
conductor de todo este viaje la relación
de la forma con la función o sea algo
que además de parecer
algo que es un poco escaso en estos días
muchas veces las cosas parecen pero no
son
pero en la naturaleza no miente y esta
dinámica por ejemplo pensemos en la cola
de un delfín es una forma preciosa es
perfecta es este diseño es completamente
hidrodinámico
entonces estamos viendo en el agua sin
generar ninguna fricción reconoce el
agua se mueve en ella y se mueve con
alegría y sin generar sin perder energía
esta relación es lo más importante de lo
que puede suceder en la naturaleza para
que se construya una tecnología
milenaria sobre la cual se soporta la
vida y que ahora podríamos empezar a
imitar
esta es un ejemplo curioso de
inteligencia estos celos sirven para
disuadir un depredador
está particularmente es muy pequeña
es una máscara
este es un niño indígena
que como veréis dibujará insistentemente
en la piedra sin lograrlo es una
parábola de lo que ha sucedido con las
culturas tempranas humanas las culturas
tempranas humanas han utilizado los
símbolos del agua para reconocer un
contacto con la realidad natural y con
una totalidad
ese dibujo del agua
está presente por ejemplo en las formas
de los griegos en los símbolos de los
griegos vemos una especie de ying yang
en su simbolismo también a nivel de
relato por ejemplo hablan de la vía
láctea y la vía láctea ahora podemos
reconocer que sí que es una espiral y
que es un vórtice y que en el centro
tiene un agujero negro la [ __ ] resulta
que los griegos ya lo sabían parece
porque estaban hablando de la leche que
cae en el agua genera un vórtice qué
curioso los griegos también tenían un
referente muy muy interesante que era la
proporción áurea y era un referente
básico que permitía que conociendo tu
casa conozcas el universo por qué
la parte menor es como la parte mayor y
la parte mayor como el todo esto como
veremos un poco más adelante es muy
importante ahora seguimos viendo
imágenes del agua y vemos como este
dibujo del flujo hace
estas líneas que se cruzan que son
flujos laminares y que están si nos
podemos observar triángulos también con
flujos laminares
estas formas están premiando todos los
símbolos de todas las culturas humanas
tempranas
luego lo que pasa después
esta conexión con la totalidad la
perdemos y entramos en una relación
diferente con el mundo y esta relación
tiene sus pros y sus contras como todo
no hay dicha completa de qué es lo que
dicen por ahí entonces estamos
aprendiendo unas cosas de un lado y
perdiendo totales del otro cuando
empezamos a mirar el mundo como un
mecanismo dejamos de tener esta
percepción que es la percepción de lo
que estáis viendo
de la forma como se está moviendo la
sangre en nuestras venas el aire que
respiramos
los flujos del viento solar
todo esto se mueve de esta manera
ya os explicaré un poco más por qué
esta es una imagen del agua es una
fotografía
no tiene ni truco ni cartón en la foto
tal cual
es un paisaje interior basado
en natura es la realidad puede dar para
abrir un mundo interior
qué es realmente os lo aseguro infinito
las formas básicas del agua son 2
para que no nos leemos una es la esfera
de la que ya hemos hablado la otra es un
vórtice
el vórtice lo vemos cotidianamente
cuando tiramos de la cadena del lavabo
[Música]
si estamos en argentina dicen que gira
al revés
porque el planeta se mueve y el agua le
hace caso al movimiento del planeta
entonces gira en un sentido opuesto
lo que vemos aquí es el delta del ebro
y lo que estamos viendo al lado de james
perdón el de esta vez es el río ebro son
los meandros del río ebro son meandros
de kilómetros de largo tanto que un
puntito blanco que veis en la parte
inferior derecha de la fotografía es una
torre de energía eléctrica muy grande ya
veis la escala de proporción que tiene
esta imagen y lo que veis también es que
el río que hace estos meandros
está
[Música]
tiene una forma similar a unos meandros
que hay en las montañas pero lo meandros
de los de las montañas están verticales
o qué curioso pues esto sucede porque
las esa formación de las montañas de eso
que parece rígido sobre lo que no
soportamos fue un flujo
entonces yo que empiezo trabajando con
el agua terminó
y mirando el flujo estas que podrían ser
partículas subatómicas es agua esto que
podría ser una cosmología es agua
esta que es una espiral es la de miedo y
es una espiral
las formas orgánicas y el agua siempre
siempre
un vórtice casi en la superficie es
precioso ese pareció un delfín
no medusa
y el agua señalando un punto en el
espacio bueno la verdad es solamente una
telaraña que estaba congelada y quedó
esta equis
bueno esta no es una foto nocturna de
nueva york que exactamente es el agua
movida por el viento
está
como hemos visto es la forma como se
mueve
del agua en calma
y ésta
es la primera aproximación
a una realidad subyacente
sobre la que estamos con la que estamos
conectados
lo que estáis viendo son ecuaciones
matemáticas ni más ni menos yo no he
puesto una línea
como no he hecho nada para contemplar el
río
este es un objeto matemático infinito
que se llama el conjunto de mandelbrot
del que podréis publicar algunas cosas
y es el mismo origen de lo que vemos
atrás
esta obra me retiraré me saldré del
círculo solo por subvertir las reglas
está hecha en este tamaño con un
propósito y es brindar al espectador la
posibilidad de estar frente a un objeto
auto similar
en el que las partes y la totalidad
están vinculadas de forma armoniosa y
coherente
esto qué es una nueva geometría del
cambio de paradigma y que señala que
todo está conectado que es la lógica en
la que entraremos a futuro cada vez con
más fuerza y con más coherencia y con
más sentido
es la realidad subyacente en la realidad
en lo que existe en la realidad natural
subyacente entonces todo este recorrido
de formas que os invito cuando tengáis
un momento acercaros porque veréis como
hay infinitas formas y cada uno de estos
puntos
como parte de un objeto matemático es
una espiral
infinita que no se acaba
esto puede dar vértigo
porque finalmente desde dentro es el
origen
es el punto en donde estamos
es esa incorruptible esencia de dónde
venimos y dónde nos nutrimos
lo que viene nos facilitará reconocer
que de esta forma nos estamos
relacionando socialmente
de que de esta forma podemos vincularnos
crecer y retroalimentarnos para
construir una realidad realmente
transformadora no por cambiar nada sino
por sacar lo que tenemos dentro
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]